Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
I'm finally back.
I have no idea what has happened while I was gone.
But we're gonna see today.
It's been another 50 years since I was in a coma again.
I was in another coma, so we're back at it again to see what else happened.
What has changed in the lands of Rust?
It's been another 84 years.
Yes, it's been another 84 years.
I couldn't stream another time because...
Oh my god!
Serves
me good!
Thank you!
For those who don't know, I had to do a work travel.
I had to do a business trip earlier to practice for my concert that's next month.
So it was very poor timing because obviously I couldn't do...
I wasn't able to stream Rust.
I was very tired.
And I didn't have the internet to stream Rust when I was there.
So, I heard there's two more days.
There's two more days left of the Rust drops.
So, if you guys don't know, I have an exclusive AK skin in Rust with Sykkuno.
Shoutout to Sykkuno for like...
Shoutout to Sykkuno for like holding the...
Helping the Dragoons get the Rust gun.
Because I couldn't stream a lot of Rust the last four days.
So, shoutout to them.
But yes, I don't know what's...
I don't know what's going on now in the server.
So, everything is gonna be very new.
We're gonna see how...
Maybe I can actually get my gun.
Maybe I can actually see what my gun looks like.
That's all I want.
I just wanna know what my gun looks like.
I don't know how long I'll be streaming today.
I'll try to get at least two hours in.
So, like those who, you know...
Those who stopped by can at least get the gun within those two hours.
Am I the only naked person on the server now?
No way.
There's no way.
Are you tired?
I was cleaning my apartment.
I actually unpacked a bit.
What does that even mean?
I can take the clothes.
There's clothes in the...
Is the castle still...
Is my fort still even there?
That's the thing.
Do I still have a house?
Do I even still have a house?
I don't know.
We're gonna find out soon.
We're gonna find out if we have...
Is it abandoned?
Is it...
Do I... Am I alive?
Am I alive?
Am I homeless?
Do I still have a home?
Does my tribe still exist?
Does the Lurklings even exist anymore?
So, we'll see.
We'll see what we're gonna find out today.
God, I hope Ted's dead.
I...
I... That's the only thing I hope for.
If anything, I hope he's fucking dead.
Fuck Ted.
Oh, there we go.
Progress Valhalla.
There we go.
Alright.
Progressive Valhalla.
Okay, let's see how...
Oh, yeah!
Yo!
Ayyy!
Oh, bro.
Wait, what happened?
Dude, what is it with you and your comas?
Sorry, how many years has it been?
I don't have time for this.
Get out of here.
Wait, no!
How many years has it been, Duncan?!
Get out.
No, get out.
How many years?!
I need to know!
Okay, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I'm waiting for someone to spawn.
There's an insider in here.
Wait, there's an insider?!
I'm watching the bags.
Okay, while you're watching the bags, give me...
Can you go on the other side?
The other side?
What do you mean?
Yeah, go all the way down there to the green bag.
And then look towards me.
And then we just wait.
We just wait.
Okay, alright.
You need to keep me up to date.
What happened?!
Is Ted still...
Wait, where's Ted?!
Oh, oh boy.
That's a long story.
Wait, wait, wait.
No, wait, no.
Where's Ted?
Go back, go back to your position.
Wait, I can't hear you from back here!
Wait, you can't hear me?
No, you're so quiet.
Because of proximity.
Okay, alright, alright.
Yeah, what happened to Ted?!
Well, Ted kind of betrayed us.
He was kind of a spy or something.
I fucking knew it!
I told you!
Yeah, you're right, you're right.
But you had a coma.
Like, what are you...
I'm not going to ask you why you had a coma.
Yeah, that's why the person with a coma can smell a rat.
Because they had no prior attachments to Ted.
They think I can smell the rat off of...
But of course...
Yeah, but of course you needed to take a nap, didn't you?
It's not my fault I went into a coma.
Like, you can't fucking wake a person up from a coma.
Okay, so what happened?
Wait, stay here and look, okay?
Okay.
Stay here, stay here.
There's a Lancer.
Who the fuck is Lancer?
Who's this guy?
Yeah.
Okay, thank you for the 10,000 bitties.
Thank you.
I told you guys!
I knew it!
I knew Ted wasn't...
I knew Ted was not it.
I knew it when Mendo was like, Ted is a spy.
And I was like, why are we still here?
Okay, guys, we need clothes.
Why am I...
Oh, yeah, because I...
I had to prove something.
Okay, I'm gonna steal...
At least I'll have this.
Okay, I'm not naked, guys.
See?
Look, now I'm part of...
Now I'm part of them.
Okay, yeah.
What just happened now?
We just had a marriage.
What?
Right now?
There was a red wedding?
Wait, why wasn't I invited to the wedding?
You could've taken my body.
You could've taken my...
You could've taken my body to the wedding.
You could've...
I could've been there physically.
Not mentally, but physically.
Okay, okay, so like...
Who was he getting...
Okay, so who was he getting married to?
You don't even know who the fuck the wife was?
Dude, so...
Do you think this is the only thing that's been happening?
I don't know.
Okay, alright, alright.
Give me the lore.
What happened?
I'm here waiting, looking at a bag.
Okay, but why?
What happened?
I might put you in a coma.
I might have to put you in a coma.
No, wait, but why?
What happened?
Why are you looking at the...
Who are we looking for?
Wait, one guy disappeared.
Oh, no, the guy disappeared.
Their body's gone.
Oh, yeah, that's fine.
That's because they're dead.
Oh, okay.
Okay, so, like, who are we waiting for?
Uh, he's a bad, bad man.
Okay, but, like, how bad is he?
Why is he a bad man?
Well, it's funny to break a roleplayer's base, I think.
I don't know.
So, I'm just protecting it.
Alright, there's a lot of stuff.
Oh, here, take this.
Do you know how to use this thing?
I thought we were not allowed to use metal.
What happened?
Okay, so, if you hold right-click, you see that bar disappearing?
That means you're ready to shoot.
Yeah.
And then, like, left-click.
Like, try and do it.
Try and do it.
Yeah.
Okay, wait, stop.
Don't spin it, though.
It uses durability, and it's very, very low.
Just stay in here for a second, okay?
Okay.
I'm just gonna go check something.
When did we get a minigun?
What the fuck happened?
I just woke up from another coma.
What the...
What?
Even Deku doesn't know what's going on.
He's like, do you mean skull?
I am with no kingdom.
Our age-long war with the Pulgarians is over.
They are our...
Who the fuck were the Pulgarians?
Was I even there?
Did you not read chat at all?
Was I even there for the fucking war against the...
The red... the D we attacked?
What did you say in chat?
Stop fucking shooting me.
That's for me.
I'm not shooting you.
Wasn't that the war I was in?
Were they the Pulgarians?
Oh, they were the Pulgarians.
So we're allies with the scary people with the guns?
I wake up to another war?
How do I keep waking up to war?
How do...
And now I have a minigun.
I...
I woke up...
Yo, this coma fucking sucks, man.
Alright, guys.
I woke up...
Hey.
Hey, twin.
So I woke up to another war that war...
I got drafted into.
Dude, I might...
I might have to put you in a coma permanently.
Wait, what?
Why?
Why did I...
Wait, where's the food?
I'm fucking...
Did you just come back?
The worst timing.
Oh, my God.
Why do we have so many pumpkins now?
Like, do we own a farm?
Alright, well, it's time to see...
I might actually do it.
I might actually put you in a coma.
No, please.
I don't know when I'll actually wake up again.
I might wake up to a new age.
Okay, alright.
I'm gonna go explore and see what the fuck is going on now.
Alright, let's see how much the world has changed again.
Okay, so they're all right now at the other kingdom.
They're in the other kingdom?
What are they doing at the other kingdom?
Don't worry about it.
How's your health?
It's at 56.
What the fuck?
Here, take this.
Take these.
Okay.
Shoot two of them.
Shoot two of them and then save that last one here I gave you.
Alright, alright.
Oh my god, I'm fucking scared to go outside now.
One second.
What the fuck?
I'm gonna make some stuff and then we go...
Wait, do we have an AK?
Do we have an AK?
Okay, you just...
You're just begging to get...
No, no, I have the exclusive AK drop.
Please, I just want to know what my skin looks like.
At least.
Oh my god.
Wait, where can I get that?
Where can I get the exclusive AK skin?
Oh, you want to know where to get my exclusive AK skin?
Well, all you have to do is just watch one hour of my stream and then you can get exclusive AK skin just for Rust.
And I have never seen it before.
I've never seen it, like, actually held it.
So that's why I was wondering.
That's why I want to know what it looks like.
Wait, give me a sec.
I'll show you.
I got one.
Wait, you stole one?
Oh.
Shh, we don't say the S word.
Oh, you borrowed it.
You borrowed it.
Wait, Blau wants us to go to him.
Yeah, like a friend of a friend.
Blau wants us to go to him.
Yeah, I know, I know.
Take that Mr. Wrench.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Take that Mr. Wrench on the ground.
I'll make a few more.
All right, let's go.
All right, let's go to Blau, I guess.
You know what time it is?
It's the Avenger time.
It's time.
I want to see how much the world has changed in 50 years.
We have art now?
Who the fuck is Sha- Sha-Hallod?
Oh, you ha- Oh my days.
What the fuck happened here?
Come with me.
No horses for...
Gathered in the pa- What the fuck is the party bus?
Um, okay, so, uh, okay, so that worm you just saw?
Yeah?
It's like kind of our guy, and you see those- you see these rocks?
Small rocks?
Yeah?
Like, all around the snow, there's landmines in them.
Wait, what?
You have to jump over them.
Oh, you just- you just heard that?
You just heard that?
That blew up?
No.
That was someone just walking into a landmine.
No, wait, there's landmines here now?
No, no.
Oh, boy.
Oh, no.
Just follow me, you should be fine.
Why is there landmines in our territory?
Oh, wait, it is not- wait, give me a sec.
This way, dude.
Okay.
Wait, do I even have your AK?
I should have it.
You have it?
Wait, do you have it?
Can you skin it?
I don't know.
I never made it, so I don't know!
Uh, go- interact with this repair bench.
Yeah?
Oh, I see it!
I see it!
I don't know this item's blueprint.
Then you just grab it.
Grab the AK.
Wait, I can just grab it?
Just grab it.
Oh, shit!
Yeah.
Alright, guys, look.
There's my gun.
Right here.
How do I inspect it?
What button do I press?
M?
N?
Oh, okay, guys, look.
There it is.
If you watch one hour of this stream, you can actually get this AK, guys.
Look at this.
It's right here.
Whoa!
We're going to war.
Oh!
We gotta go.
Oh, we gotta go, go.
Just put the AK up here.
Wait, why can't I bring it?
They'll never know.
Alright, it's fine.
You got the minigun, right?
Yeah, I got the minigun.
Alright, let's go, let's go.
Alright, to war.
I get drafted to another war, I guess.
Well, that's why...
It's a forever skin.
You get it forever, guys.
You get to keep it forever.
We finally get to touch the skin.
Guys, we are straight into war.
Well, I'm ready.
I'm ready to go straight...
What?
Oh, my God.
I hope those...
Are those helicopters people?
Yeah, they're with us.
Oh, okay.
They're with us?
Oh, hey, there's a polar bear.
Oh, there was a polar bear.
If I just randomly knock you out, just know there's a reason.
There's a reason?
Wait, why?
What did I do?
I literally...
I just got up.
What?
Remember, watch out for these small rocks.
Wait, wait, wait.
Just watch out, okay?
What?
It could be any one of these rocks.
Oh, my God.
I need to follow your footprints.
Why did you guys mine up the entire area?
Oh, my God.
Guys, now I can look at the floor.
I could blow up at any second.
Honestly, I ask that question every day.
Oh, okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, what?
You see that right there?
Yeah.
You see that little brown piece?
That's a landmine.
That's a landmine?
Shoot it.
So, try...
No, stand on top of it.
No.
You don't die.
Just stand on top of it.
No, I know.
That's a landmine.
Did you hear that?
Yeah.
That little...
Okay, so now come over to me and then pick it up.
Otherwise, I can't move.
Oh.
Oh, there you go.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
Okay, and then I put it...
Okay, there you go.
Oh, my God.
That's so fucked up.
That is actually so fucked up.
The amount of times I've died...
Who planted all these mines?
Who was it?
I think everybody started doing it.
Everybody?
Yeah, I don't even know.
Oh, my God.
Alright, who are we going to war now?
Who are we going to war with this time?
DJ Claw.
Alright.
Okay.
Wait, why am I seeing...
Wait.
Wait, why is Felicity and Elim in a car?
Why are they in a car?
Did you get them?
Is that them?
Wait, the people that got kidnapped are in that car.
Elim, is that you guys?
Can they hear us?
Wait, wait.
Is that them under the kidnappers?
I can't tell if they got freed or what's going on here.
I honestly can't tell.
Wait.
Are they...
Wait, is that...
Wait, are we supposed to save them?
I...
Honestly, when I heard Elim got kidnapped, I was kind of...
Honestly, I was kind of relieved.
But I guess we gotta...
I mean, they got foolish as well.
And I think he's the useful one.
Oh, right.
Yeah, I think we gotta save the...
We gotta save the one that's actually useful.
Well, I mean, I guess Elim is just there with him, so...
Yeah, like, he's just like the plus one.
We gotta pick.
We just pick foolish, right?
We just pick foolish if we have to pick.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, I think they were kidnapped.
I think we literally just saw the kidnappers.
Wait, let me...
Let me talk in team.
Team chat.
Let me type in team chat.
So, like...
Wait, was that them?
Was that just them?
Did they drop them off?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, was that...
I think those were the kidnappers.
I think they dropped them off.
No, no, no, no, no.
It wasn't, it wasn't, it wasn't.
I thought it was.
It's not this kid.
I thought it was, but it's not.
Oh my god, they ran over a bear.
Honestly, I'm so confused.
I don't even know what's going on.
I'm gonna wait.
Let me type in team chat real quick.
I don't even know.
Did we...
Are Ellum and Foolish still kidnapped?
We just saw their car.
We just saw their...
Yeah, that was...
We literally saw their car.
We literally just saw them drive by.
That's hilarious.
Oh, we saw...
We saw them.
Whoops.
Catch your breath.
Yeah, I'm catching my breath.
I'm catching...
We're good.
Well, bye.
Was that them?
Okay, so those were the kidnappers.
That's the kidnappers.
And that was Foolish and Ellum.
I'm not sure what's going on.
I'm as confused as you are.
We saw...
Wait, give me like a minute.
I gotta think.
I don't even know what the fuck is going on.
Well, bye Ellum.
They just went to our camp.
What the fuck is going on?
Can we run the other way?
I mean, they're at our camp now.
Why are they doing it?
But they're still kidnapped.
They said they're still kidnapped.
I feel like you right now.
I actually don't know what's going on.
We should landmine the road.
We should...
Wait, be careful.
You might stand on a landmine.
Hey, worry about yourself, okay?
Oh, alright.
If you stand on a landmine.
Oh,
now you're paranoid.
Now you're paranoid.
You don't want to have...
It wasn't a coma, okay?
Yeah, but you know just as much information as me right now.
Like...
We're so lost, guys.
We're so lost.
Wait, wait, is that them?
That's them.
Yeah, turn it off.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's them.
That's them over there.
This way, this way, this way.
Watch out, watch out for the rocks.
Did they throw them off?
Wait, I'm going to shoot them.
I'm going to shoot them.
They're looking.
They're confused.
Do I shoot back?
Okay,
look.
This is a minigun.
This is...
I don't know how to control this.
They shot back!
They're shooting back!
Follow me, follow me.
We gotta go this way.
Spray and pray.
Spray and...
I think I hit somebody.
Good shit, good shit.
Can I get it in?
Wait.
You guys are alive!
Wait, you guys are alive!
What happened?
It was bad, guys.
We shot them off.
Was that a good thing?
It was bad.
It did go bad.
Guys, they made it.
Yeah, we just shot at them.
They ripped up the wedding papers and then Coconut forced me to marry him.
Even kissed me on the lips.
Oh!
We're married!
Yeah.
I'm married to Coconut!
Wait, I need to be sad.
Wait, what's wrong?
What's wrong with marrying Coconut?
What's wrong?
They're bad people.
Oh, wait!
We're allied with them?
But if we kick you out, then we're not allied with them anymore.
Oh, I guess.
Yeah.
If we kick out Ellen, for the greater good.
You don't have to be allied.
Like, if you care about us.
Yeah.
If you care about us, you'd leave our group.
It's time to leave.
Wait, you got a fine-ass fit.
What the hell?
If that's what has to be done.
It was like a wedding gift.
If you...
If you hate them as much as we do, you would sacrifice yourself for the greater good.
I got married too, actually.
Wait, wait, wait.
Who did you get married to?
He's also married to the DJ.
Fuck, I...
I don't remember.
Who did I get married to?
Wait, who did you get married to?
I got married to Pang.
Oh, Pang!
Okay, but you're useful, so like...
Okay, then we have a problem.
Then we have to...
Then we have to keep you two, so...
I mean, like, how do you get divorced?
How can we get...
If we kill off Coconut...
If we kill Coconut, does that mean you guys are divorced, technically?
I don't know.
Cause like, you're not married if they're dead.
No.
So, that should be how...
It's death do us part!
Then death will do you a part!
That's what it means!
Till death do us part!
Wait, do you need snacks?
Do you need snacks?
No, I'm good.
I'm good.
Oh my god, there's frog chairs?!
Wait, this place has...
Wait, was this the wedding?
It was the wedding.
This was the wedding?
Doggie, lock in, lock in.
It was the wedding.
Oh, this was the wedding.
Yeah, lock in, lock in, okay?
This is such a beautiful...
And I wasn't even invited.
I was literally next door to the wedding.
Dude.
You were invited, but you were napping.
I was literally next door.
Oh my god, look at all these frog chairs.
That means we're married.
Wait, what?
There's no priest.
There's no priest here.
Alright, so okay, now I've been filled in on the lore.
I've been filled in on the lore now.
LM has been forced to leave the Lurkings by...
They blamed you!
Nice.
Never my fault.
It's never my fault.
Wait, there's somebody over outside.
Who's that over there?
Wait, there he is.
No, he doesn't have...
LM!
Come back!
Wait, is it actually better?
LM!
LM, come back!
We have a plan!
Wait, we do?
Till death do us part!
We just gotta kill Coconut!
LM!
LM, get your ass over here!
Where the fuck is he?
LM!
LM, stop!
Don't do it!
LM, you have so much to live for!
LM!
No, we have a plan, LM!
You know in marriage, in marriage, you know the whole thing?
Till death do us part?
We just need to kill Coconut.
And then death will separate you.
So there's a chance?
There's a chance!
You just gotta kill Coconut!
You gotta lure him!
And then kill him!
Cause you're married, right?
So then as a married couple, you can lure him to a secluded place.
And then we'll kill him.
And then you're legally separated because till death do us part.
That's basically it.
And that's how you fix marriage.
Are you ready to kill your husband?
Can you do it?
Can you look into his eyes and stab him?
Alright.
Alright, message him.
Take him to a secluded place.
Say that you wanna go on a honeymoon with him.
Listen.
Tunnels are banned, okay?
No tunnel things, okay?
Let's go.
All you have to do is tell him you wanna go on a honeymoon.
Then lead him to a secluded area.
I think that's the car that they kidnapped him in.
Wait, what?
That's the car.
It's not that one.
It's not that one?
That's not the kidnapper car?
Alright, how are you gonna lure a coconut?
How are you gonna do it, LM?
I don't know.
Do you not even have like private messages with your husband?
No, I was forced into it.
Yeah, but you're still married.
He made me do it, donkey.
Yeah, but like, now you gotta do a couple things.
What a bad husband.
You know what?
I'm gonna message Coconut for you.
Coconut, where are you?
Your husband misses you.
There we go.
There, maybe he'll reply back.
This is very poor communication.
I don't even know what's going on.
And I've been here the whole time.
I gotta save their marriage and then break it.
Bro, your husband isn't even responding to me.
He wants to talk to you, LM.
Live, laugh, love.
Okay.
I'm like scared of walking through this area now.
Everything is a landmine.
Everything is literally a landmine.
Where do I go?
Are you fucking serious?
There's landmines within the headquarters.
Where is, where is, which rock?
I don't know.
I woke up and there's war and now, like, what's going on anymore?
I'm too scared to travel because there's landmines everywhere.
Oh, ow, my toes.
Where are these new people?
Landmines, so many bullets, so many bodies.
Oh, my God.
Like, we're...
Okay, alright, so...
Alright, so...
We're back here.
What happened?
Wait, did you guys, what happened?
What, what, what happened?
I'm shaking and afraid.
I'm naked and afraid.
Did you guys all die?
People were getting inside.
I can't even...
We were almost lost in clothes.
I killed a couple of them.
They got to the TC.
Yeah, but I had to protect them while you guys were gone.
They kept coming.
We found element foolish.
They got married.
Yeah, so they got married.
Yeah, Ellen's trying to plan to murder Coconut now.
So, like, he's doing that right now.
Oh, my God, I hate Coconut.
Where's Blau?
Sir Ellen, where's Blau?
We tried.
Blau is still dying for you, Sir Ellen.
I rallied the North for you, brother.
We tried.
The blood that was spilled, the families that were sacrificed in your honor to retrieve you and your wife.
Lord Elo.
Lord Elo, have you married to the enemy?
Wait, what?
He's married to Coconut.
No.
He's married to Coconut now.
We sacrificed so much.
Yes, Blau.
We have to kill Coconut.
Till death do us part.
Yes, you have unified the North, Sir Ellen.
Egregious attack upon the Coldstone.
The sacrilege the House Dijon Claw has committed, as well as our first unification.
I feel like I just showed up in, like, season 5, episode 30.
You will never forget what Dijon Claw did here today.
Exactly.
You're just hanging out up there.
Well hung, I see.
Elam, what about the countless souls?
Nice, nice.
What about the countless souls that were sacrificed in your marriage's honor?
Are you just gonna throw them away?
Are we just gonna brush them off like they're dust in the wind?
This does not sit well with me.
We fight back.
Why are you mirroring the enemy?
I know how you feel, Lord Shaki, but listen.
Lord Elam was the only reason why we even got Lord Blau back in the first place.
What?
So Coconut just went for a second Lord of Command.
Coconut just hurt my mental.
I'm pretty sure Lady Dookie has no idea what the fuck is going on.
Guys, I just woke up from a coma, guys.
Everyone...
Lore speedrun recap time.
Madam Dookie, listen.
Many years ago, we have fought a battle called Skyfall.
We have rained down from the flying mythical beast dragon with parachutes, bows, and swords.
Led by the commander, Lord Blau.
What did we kill him?
What did we just kill?
We killed Foolish.
Alright, Dookie, listen.
So what happened was, Elam was getting married.
We all went to the wedding.
The wedding was a bloodbath.
It was an insanely horrendous accident.
The incident that happened, everybody was dying.
There was bodies flying.
There was blood raining from the skies.
We partnered up with Paulgarians.
We were going to take them back.
They were kidnapped by Coco.
Him, Foolish, and...
Wait, who did you get married to?
You, no?
Okay, Uni.
So Uni, they were all kidnapped by Coco.
We, all of us, we joined together.
We were in the bang bus.
And we traveled very far.
We got there.
We set war.
We set fire amongst their city.
And apparently, Elam got married to the enemy and let his wife die.
And now we're here.
Our families, our friends spilled blood on the battlefield.
Body parts were flying.
People were dying.
I am all for blaming Elam.
I want you guys to know something, okay?
Elam, as a Lord Commander, is absolutely useless.
Elam does absolutely jack shit.
Wait, Coconut, the guy from that story you were telling.
There he is.
He's in that story.
What are you doing here?
Denounce your marriage.
I loved you.
I took you in as my husband.
And then your people attacked me after I let you go.
Consider this a warning.
We're coming to burn all this shit down.
We gotta call Red.
We gotta call Red, guys.
Guys, we gotta call Red.
We need help.
We need to go ask Pogarians.
Help us.
My Lord.
This is bad.
My Lord, this is bad.
We need to prepare.
My Lord.
My Lord, this is bad.
What do we do?
We have no ammunition.
We have no crossbow.
We're all out.
Oh my God.
I just...
I...
What?
Oh my God!
Okay.
Everybody calm down.
Clearly, everything will be fine.
Right?
Right, Jackie?
Everything will be fine, right, Jackie?
Everything.
Theo died.
I watched Theo die right in front of me.
Guys, I don't think everything is going to be fine.
Right?
I don't think we...
I think I ruined the peace talk.
Wait.
Guys, I think it was me and Jackie's fault.
I think it was me and Jackie's fault.
I think I actually...
I think I ruined the peace talk.
I am so sorry.
We have no weapons.
We're out.
But my father only lived until he was 50!
How can we live for a thousand years?
Oh my God!
I started this war!
And they don't know!
We must go contact the Bulgarians.
I actually started this war!
Oh no!
They don't know.
They don't know it was me all along.
I don't say a word.
I won't say a word.
Don't say anything, Doki.
They don't know.
They don't know it was me all along.
They don't...
Guys, I...
Guys, I need to tell Dakin.
Guys, I don't think they know it was me.
I need to...
I need to go tell Dakin.
We gotta keep our mouths shut.
We gotta...
We gotta keep it shut.
We gotta get our stories right.
We gotta get it right.
Alright, we have to...
We have to get our stories straight.
The moment we get our stories straight, then it'll be fine.
We'll be fine.
Yeah?
I've got something to admit to you, Doki.
What is it?
My wife...
Yeah?
Gunned down in broad daylight.
I looted her body for 500 scrap.
I'm gonna take it over to the casino and make it big, man.
This is your last day.
Before we die...
Before we die, you're gonna get...
You're gonna get...
Dakin, Dakin, we started a war.
Dakin, Dakin, Dakin.
We gotta keep our stories straight.
When we shot them, it was our fault.
Right, right.
Um, LM, by the way, even though you...
I mean, you're probably gonna die anyway, so I'm gonna just tell you.
I stole Foosley's 3k scrap.
When she got rogged at it.
No one's gonna believe you anymore.
I mean, we're all gonna die today anyway.
Might as well make some confessions today.
Dakin, we gotta...
They cannot know that we started this war, Dakin.
We can't...
Wait, okay, Doki.
What if we leave?
Coconut...
We just leave this country?
Coconut came over and said that we shot at...
Somebody shot at him when they dropped off LM.
And now that he's starting a war against us, he's gonna burn everything down.
We cannot admit it was our...
We cannot tell them it was us.
Wait, wait, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh.
Be quiet, be quiet, be quiet.
Go, go, go, go.
We're the reason why they're gonna burn our town.
It's our fault.
Go upstairs, go upstairs.
Come over here.
Listen.
Nobody can fucking know.
Are you serious?
Is that the reason?
That's why.
They literally said we dropped off LM and wanted peace talks, but you guys shot at us.
And it was us.
It was us, Duncan.
We were the ones that shot at them.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, we got two options, right?
Do we do?
What do we do?
Fight or we can flee.
We can flee the country.
We can get some new identities.
Live a new life.
We can be ignorant.
We can be ignorant, right?
As long as we don't tell them it was us.
We just deny.
Yeah, you know what?
Yeah, you can stay here and fight.
I'll just flee the country.
We're gonna leave.
When you're done.
I'm leaving.
You can stay.
You're leaving the Lurk League after...
Okay, I'll leave.
Wait, can you give me an AK, though?
If you can give me an AK, I'll leave, too.
Oh, no.
Sorry.
No, you want to be here and defend, right?
No, no, no, no.
I'm fine with leaving.
I gotta go.
No, you know what?
No, you're right.
You're right.
Maybe it's not worth fighting here.
Oh, yeah?
Yeah, I mean, how...
Okay, I've never encountered the Pagarians, but like, how scary are they?
How scary are the Pagar... whatever they're called?
We have a chance, but we need them to call us.
We need to let them know.
We have a chance?
Like, call them.
Like, what do you mean by call them?
Are you a spy?
No, I just got a phone.
Listen, I'm a businessman.
What can I say?
Wait.
Were you living a double life this entire time, Dakin?
Listen.
Listen, it's hard to explain, really.
Wait a minute.
Is this why you have all these guns?
Hey, yeah, I mean...
Were you...
You know, if you were there, you know, you would've known.
I mean, it's all...
Wait, who's calling you?
You know what?
Hello, this is Dakin.
What's up, Ray?
Um, so, Kogana just dropped by and he said that they dropped off Ellum and Foolish.
First of all, they're married to DJ Inklaw now, right?
But they dropped them off, and they said that someone shot at them while they dropped them off.
And that's the reason they're gonna try and burn our whole camp down now.
They're gonna come and raid us.
So, uh...
Yeah, they're gonna raid the Lurglings, yeah.
What's going on?
What are you listening to?
What?
Yeah, it's a code fucking red.
It's a code fucking red.
Are you sure you're gonna tell everyone?
It doesn't sound like you are.
Dakin, there are shots fired.
I will literally jump in there, I'll slap you across the face, and I'll tell everybody if you don't do it.
Make Jimin call me, ASAP.
What's going on?
Alright, bye, miss you.
Oh yeah, right.
Yeah, you wanted to stay here.
No, no, no, I'm fleeing.
I'm fleeing, too.
No, I just heard the first shots of war.
I'm out.
Ooh, sorry.
What do you mean, ooh?
I gotta take my business suit on.
Wait, what do you mean, ooh?
I'm a busy guy.
What the fuck?
I got my business suit on.
Where did you get all this?
Listen, I'm a busy guy.
I'm a busy guy.
What?
Can you get out?
Okay, okay.
Can we at least get an AK after everything we've been through?
Can we at least get my AK?
Hey, listen, you got one of those miniguns.
They're way better than an AK.
Yeah, but that's my skin.
Scram, scram, get out.
Scram.
I can't believe you'd leave me behind.
It's my skin now.
You can get on my channel now.
Scram.
What the?
What?
What happened?
No, I should have said yes to fleeing the country.
What just happened?
You fool.
Oh my god, wait.
Wait, maybe I can snitch on him.
The man who sold the world.
I...
We had a minigun.
You're right.
I need to find a landmine.
I can't believe it.
What the fuck just happened?
He was never... He lived a double life.
Wait.
I don't even know how to get back in.
The event ends at like 3pm tomorrow.
Oh my god.
Everything happened.
And now I'm all alone.
I should have fled the country.
I need to tell him.
I need to tell Blau.
Did you win, LM?
Did you win it big?
You never made it?
Wait, wait.
Do you have an extra landmine?
Oh yeah, nice.
I need some extra landmines.
Thanks.
Oh my god.
How the fuck did you make this jump?
I'm gonna do it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I need some landmines.
Oh, thanks.
I got him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, thanks.
Don't worry.
I got an idea on where to put him.
Thanks, man.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it, man.
Be careful.
Don't blow up.
Don't worry.
I know the map.
I sure do love living at my house.
What?
You can't place it?
This is bullshit.
This is actually bullshit.
Hey.
What are you guys talking in there?
What are you guys talking over there?
Huh?
What were you guys talking over there?
What do you mean, who's we?
Yeah?
Who were you talking to?
Who was it?
Oh, somebody.
A dirty little secret?
Why not?
Oh.
Hey.
Whoa.
Whoa, man.
Listen.
It's not what it looks like.
Okay.
What is it supposed to look like?
I was just talking to my...
Well, man, that's a good question.
I didn't think you'd ask that question.
But it's not that.
Whatever you were thinking, it wasn't that.
What would I be thinking about?
You know what?
You have the darndest imagination.
Anyone ever tell you that?
Whoa.
You got a big gun.
Yeah.
Wow.
Okay.
Yeah.
Fine.
I was talking to my ex-roommate.
Your ex-roommate?
Why is he back there?
I don't actually know.
Why is he still hiding inside your house?
As if nothing is happening.
That's a good question.
Yeah, why isn't he even saying anything after all of that?
Why is he putting you in such an uncomfortable position right now?
By yourself, right here.
So uncomfortable.
Yeah, isn't it so uncomfortable?
And he just lets you stand there by yourself?
It doesn't really work.
It's like you can clearly see him on the mini-map.
Yeah, and he's letting you just stand there with this awkward situation.
And he's not even going to help you.
He's just doing his own thing in the house.
Yeah, so is he really a good friend of yours?
No, you're right.
I'm starting to think that.
Yeah.
I mean, it's just so awkward here.
Talking to somebody you don't...
You've helped me realize a lot.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like a real person, a real bro, he wouldn't let you just stand there in this awkward position.
Yeah, no.
You know what?
He'll probably prove himself any second.
Fine, fine, fine.
You can flee the country with me.
Are you happy?
Alright, best of luck, everyone.
We're actually fleeing?
I mean, shit.
It's definitely on my mind for sure.
Wait, what the fuck was Foolish doing then?
Is he also part of fleeing?
No, this is our house, Fookin.
He just lives here.
We live here.
Yeah, so you're letting him die here too?
Why the fuck do you have a Minecraft sword?
Well, if he wants to die, he will.
Hey, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
What?
Wait, so you're just going to let him die?
Yeah, well, I mean, if he wants to die, you know.
Alright, I mean, that's fine.
I'm not going to stop asking questions.
Oh, that's true.
He's like part of the problem too.
So I guess, wait, how are we supposed to flee the country?
How are we supposed to flee this area?
We just buy a boat.
That direction, like 40.
We can buy a boat and we just flee the country.
We just flee?
That's it?
Is that easy?
Wait, is that easy?
Wait, weren't you just assigned a task by Flao?
To gather loot?
Yeah, I just said yeah, whatever.
Oh, but you're not going to do it?
I'm just going to leave.
Oh, okay.
Well, I guess we can leave whenever.
I feel like we should watch a little bit of the war.
At least, like, see what's going to happen.
Aren't you a little curious?
Aren't you a little curious about what's going to happen?
Huh?
Aren't you curious?
I don't really care, honestly.
You don't care?
You don't want to watch?
I'm just trying to get my money up, you know?
Okay.
I do it for the thrill, what can I say?
Okay, okay, you gotta explain to me about the whole business side.
Like, what was all that about?
Oh, my days.
Okay, but can you stop going into a coma every single time?
I promise, this is the last coma.
This is my last coma.
Wait, wait, wait a minute.
I'm reading something.
Give me a sec.
It says that starting 12 AM PST tonight...
Wait, I think there's some event that's going to happen.
Wait, when is...
Wait.
Like, five hours?
The rock is under attack.
Wait, this is...
Wait.
They're here.
Wait, really?
Yeah, they're here.
They said they need you, Dakin.
Oh, my God.
I guess I can't leave or whatever.
Oh, you're not gonna flee.
Oh, I knew it.
I knew you couldn't flee.
You're weak.
Sprinklebells, are you here?
They're weak.
I knew it.
I knew he was weak all along.
The rock is under attack?
Everything seems okay.
Wait, is that the rock?
Oh, my God.
They're fucking here.
Oh, fuck.
They're here.
Run.
We gotta run.
I'm running.
That was a fucking Terminator gun.
Here we are, bows and arrows.
Bows and fucking arrows.
That gun was enough for 14 people.
What is this?
Oh, my God.
The siege.
There's nades.
Because I shot first!
No, I didn't shot first.
Dakin shot first.
Oh my god.
So many deaths.
I can't believe it.
Me and Dakin.
We started for all of this.
Oh my god.
We started that.
My old home.
Oh, there's a helicopter coming over now.
I...
I can't believe it.
This is where I used to live.
I made this all happen.
All those gunshots over there.
I did that.
It was all me.
Yeah.
They won't run this far.
What, do you think they'll know?
You think...
They'll...
They'll know it was me all along?
I must live for my sins, I...
Oh my god!
Excuse me?
Now we have aerial attack?
Not the air force.
Oh my god.
Rally the search winkles.
The journalistic moment.
Oh my god.
It's our heli.
Yeah, that's our helicopter.
I think...
I'm gonna reconvene.
I'm gonna reconvene with the... with the boys down there.
With Twinkles and Dakken.
This is crazy.
I did all... I caused this to happen.
I can't believe it.
I did all of that.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's not...
Okay.
Oh.
Yeah.
I'm alive.
I made... I just...
I made it.
Yeah.
Wait.
What is this?
What are you growing here?
Wait a minute, Twinkles.
Were you living a double life too?
Twinkles.
What is this?
Okay, hello.
Can you hear me now?
Yeah, we... Were you also living a double life?
No, no.
This is just a farm.
This was for food for us and...
Yeah, but why are you holding a gun and change your entire outfit?
Oh, because we don't have any more outfits.
This is what I had to put on so I'm not cold.
And I got all our guns that we saved for tomorrow.
Oh, okay.
It was just gone.
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
It's a likely story, but okay.
You hungry?
Oh, yeah.
I'm hungry.
Yeah.
Yeah, I just...
Just got out of a fucking war.
There's some potatoes in here in the middle one.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, I did not expect it to show up that fast.
Yeah, no.
I just, you know, I heard gunshots and I ran.
So like...
Yeah.
Yeah, like I don't know.
I saw like 10 people with like, you know, every type of gun possible.
And then I was like, I think we should go.
Yeah, like I don't think we were gonna live that.
And like...
And like, you know, this is all LM's fault for starting this war.
He used to have...
You mentioned it.
He did get mad at you, so you know.
Yeah, yeah.
It was his fault.
Yeah.
Like, I literally woke up and then like, people started dying.
Like...
Yeah, it started off as a very quiet day.
I guess I jinxed it by saying, um, today's a calm day.
Yeah, I don't...
So what's the plan right now?
Like, what...
Whoa!
Who's out there?
Get in here!
Deal!
1-3-1-3!
Are you okay?
We are live!
You still have your clothes!
I don't feel okay.
Okay.
Yeah, I found some more.
Dakin is getting scrapped, so we...
So we can get a boat and just boat away.
We're just leaving.
We're fleeing the country, right?
I'm really scared.
Yeah.
I'm so scared.
They're dying to the landmines!
Did you hear that?
Who?
Beautiful bliss of...
Wait, I have more landmines.
Can we put it outside the base?
I just put a bunch out there.
They're in the rocks everywhere.
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright, so we're all...
We're all getting a boat and we're leaving, right?
We're never coming back here.
Right?
Yeah, I think this is fucked.
I think... I think we got...
We should like, get new...
We should just get new identities.
Yeah, I got...
Yeah.
I got it off one of their bodies.
That's the one that shot at us.
Yeah, I got one... I got it off one of their bodies.
Are you guys good?
Yeah.
Is everybody good?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think we can...
I think this is it.
This is the squad.
Wait, wait, wait.
Raise your hands.
I wanna see what you guys got.
Make sure you guys...
Oh, I got a lot.
Okay.
Twingos, you got worms?
Sure.
Wait, can I...
Theo?
Theo, Theo, loot up, please.
Go, go, go get some stuff.
Guys, get some loot.
I don't know what you want me to get.
Just something...
Something you think that's valuable.
I don't have...
I had... My entire inventory is valuable.
It's only food.
Here, there's nothing.
Oh, right.
There's... I mean, food is nice.
Guys, listen.
Guys.
Yeah?
Guys, come here, come here.
Listen, I cannot die.
Look, this is what I got.
I cannot die.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Wait, who just stole 1k scr...
Yeah.
That was not me.
You know, my thing is full.
What?
Theo.
Hands up.
You're wrong.
I cannot believe I...
Oh.
I cannot believe this.
Wait.
Don't you?
Horrible.
You're a one, one bad person.
Oh, Theo.
Theo, baby, baby.
There you go.
Alright, you guys made it to later.
Yeah, we made it.
Guys, we don't have time for this.
We gotta leave.
We gotta flee, okay?
We're so confident when it comes to you.
Alright, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, let me look, let me look.
Alright, everybody out.
Go, go, go.
Everybody out.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, Theo, go!
They're fucking each other.
Theo, just go!
Are we going to the left?
There's a fucking tuna roll in my mouth.
I was...
Guys, I hear gunshots behind us.
I will never look back.
Yeah, we're fine.
We're okay.
Um, I think I'm having one torch.
Guys, this is very important.
We don't die, okay?
We have a lot of stuff on us.
I should've grabbed food.
What do you mean?
That entire base was full of Theo.
That entire base was full of food.
Dude, I'm panicking.
I'm panicking.
You don't understand.
I told you they were coming.
And this is the squad we end up with.
This is...
This is not the A team.
You know what people call this squad?
The Looney Tunes, okay?
This is not the A team right now.
You're for the Looney Tunes.
The Looney Tunes was a good show to watch, so maybe we're not that bad.
Okay, I am...
Twinkies, you're the first one that dies.
We're offering you.
Okay.
Yay.
The Z team.
Why me?
Yeah, because that means it's not gonna be me.
I didn't try.
What do you mean you didn't try?
I thought you had a whole plan and everything.
Oh, frick.
Wait, give me a sec.
I'm not sure if it works.
Uh -oh.
Uh-oh.
We need to get new identities, guys.
Oh, we got a boat.
We got a boat.
We got it!
Wait.
Yes!
Wait, hopefully it's enough.
Witness protection!
Everybody in!
We're all gonna be okay!
We're gonna leave!
We're fleeing the country!
This is basically...
This is basically a wipe, right?
We're leaving.
We're gonna...
We're gonna be new people.
Guys, look to the left.
This is what we're gonna miss.
Oh, man.
I hope I don't go into another coma.
Oh, my God.
Goodbye,
The Great Rock.
No, our base is still...
Our lab, because my...
My bed is still there.
Oh, my bed is not there!
Never...
Yeah, we need...
We need to sign out and be new people.
We gotta...
We gotta go to our team and change our names after this.
You wanna be a Joey?
Yeah?
You wanna be a...
You could be any name and you chose Kevin.
You could be anybody.
Out of every name you can pick...
And now you hiding in plain sight!
That's true.
No one wants to be a Kevin.
You're gonna be Jose?
Oh, my God.
Oh, you're true!
True!
You could be like, I'm new here.
Like, I'm a...
Like, I literally just moved here.
Yeah!
You should practice!
Yeah, yeah, you can't speak English, so there's no way we're like, you know...
We're like the Lurklings.
They'll never know.
Okay, I think you guys should change...
We should all change our clothes.
We look very Lurkling.
Do we even have new change of clothes?
This is literally Lurkling outfit.
I forgot my suit.
Guys, I forgot my suit.
Are we turning back for your suit?
Are you serious, Dakin?
You think I'm crazy?
Hell no!
Wait...
I'm not dying for no suit.
Why are they all gathering back to the base?
Did they...
Did they win the war?
Wait, guys.
Check the map.
They're all like, gathered there.
You think they won?
Wait, do you think...
Do you think the war is over?
Wait, I think they won the war.
We won!
Okay, everybody.
Okay, relax.
Breathe.
Okay.
Okay, everyone just breathe.
Let's just take a moment.
Let's figure out...
Guys, guys.
I think we...
You can't say we won the war when you flee.
We don't know that.
They don't know that.
We don't know...
No, no, no!
We're gonna be fired!
They don't know that.
They don't know that we flee.
We don't know we flee.
I don't wanna be here.
They don't know we flee.
Wait, no!
Jack, wait!
Okay, it's fine.
We remember all the loot you have.
We drive back.
We drive back and we just say we were part of...
We were part of the war.
Just...
We gotta get our story straight, guys.
We were there.
We were on a supply run.
We were all there.
We were just getting supplies.
We were...
We were all there.
We fought so hard.
We killed...
We killed one guy and that's how I got the minigun.
Just remember that.
We killed him with a crossbow and stole his minigun.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then we showed them our guns and be like, this is how we killed them.
And we are chasing people that are running away.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We were chasing people that were running away and that's why we were gone.
Alright, let's go back.
No, no.
Go back, Jack.
I think they won the war.
They're all grouped up.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm not going back until I get a confirmation.
We won the war, Jack.
And we...
Stop saying we won the war.
We won the war!
We won the war.
We didn't have balls.
We've won the war.
We won the war.
We clearly won the war.
Did they really die?
No, look at the map.
Why is no one responding?
Look at the map.
Yeah, but no one's responding.
He doesn't get it, Doki.
He doesn't get it.
No, they might all be prisoners.
Did we rescue them?
We rescued them.
We...
We could be heroes, Dakin.
Go ahead, go swim.
Doki, pull up with the minigun.
No, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I pulled up the minigun, and then I mowed them all down, Dakin.
Just think about that.
Dakin, just think about it.
We could be heroes.
Okay, listen, listen.
Listen, listen.
Okay, okay, listen, listen.
Theo and Doki, you guys can leave.
Twinkles and I are fleeing.
Twinkles, you wouldn't.
Twinkles, come on.
Go save him.
Twinkles, you know you want to save him.
I like blacking.
Twinkles.
I like surviving.
Twinkles, we won the war, Twinkles.
You know we won the war.
Get off my boat.
Can you drop us off a little closer?
Yeah, can you drop us a little closer, though?
Hey, listen, we gotta go.
Nope.
That's all you guys.
You guys want to be the heroes all of a sudden.
No, I'm not saying we're going to be the heroes.
Okay, I'm not saying we're going to be heroes.
I'm just saying we won the war, clearly.
Clearly, we won the war.
I am the...
Yeah, everybody's at home celebrating.
They're all drunk.
That's why they're not replying.
Yes, yes.
Look, look, look, look.
Yes.
She told you.
See?
Look.
He should have believed the whole time.
You should have believed in Plow.
See?
You should have believed in him.
Okay, all right.
Let's get our story straight.
We...
Oh, we must move all...
Surprise.
Oh, so we got to move anyways.
Oh, okay.
Well, that's fine.
Oh, okay, okay.
Then we can use the boat.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, see?
I told you we won.
I told you.
No, no, no.
The boat is slower, but I mean...
No, I knew it.
Where the hell is Helm's Deep, bro?
Listen, but guys, guys.
Okay, we got to, we got to, we got to figure out a story here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because people are going to ask where we were, right?
Yeah.
We're doing a supply run.
Yeah, we were just grabbing stuff from the super secret base that we have.
Yeah, yeah.
And we like bump into some of them.
We killed people and stole their minigun.
Yeah, yeah.
Stole their minigun, yeah.
Over here, yeah.
Okay, that one's not going to work.
We got to come up with something better.
Nah, it'll totally work.
We were chasing after some of the people that were running off and we got a boat to chase after them.
Then we killed them and stole their minigun.
It's going to be fine.
The story's going to work.
They're going to work.
Listen, I...
If it was, if it was H2, we wouldn't believe us.
But Blau will believe us.
Yeah, Blau will believe me.
Blau raided me last time, so he'll believe me.
How is Gullum?
We're going the wrong way, Daniel.
No, no, no, this is fine.
Like, right here.
Let me just go, like, straight east.
Okay.
That's the easiest way for us.
It'll be fine.
We're going to drop stuff off.
Okay.
We got to walk, we got to walk a little bit.
Alright, be careful of the mines.
Aren't mines, like, literally everywhere?
Deal.
Oh, we're so far away.
There's no, there's no mines.
We're not even close.
Yeah, we're going to have to go back to our base.
And we have to get whatever we have there.
If it's not completely destroyed.
We'll be fine, guys.
I think our base is fine.
Everything will be fine.
Hey, listen.
Me and Dagger were getting shot at when we were running outside.
So, maybe...
Yeah, this, this, this Twinkle Bails here.
We're just, I'll tell him, run down to the, to the, to the head base.
I did if you could see that.
I'm right behind you, I'm shooting.
Everything will be fine, chat.
Everything will be fine.
They don't know.
We try to flee the country.
You don't know, guys.
Because if they know, that's stream sniping.
And that's against the rules.
You don't know.
Somebody in my chat said that.
It's funny that you, you're a wire dodger in GTA, considering you're a GTA...
Uh, in Rust, considering you're a GTA lord.
Wait, who is that?
Don't hurt me!
Woah, woah, woah, freeze!
Who's this?
Who is this?
Are you...
Oh, no.
Hey, who are you?
What?
Are you a loner?
Are you part of a kingdom?
Freehold?
Oh.
I know, he's chill.
Actually, wait.
Hey, rummy your pockets.
Hands up.
What?
What, why?
Actually, actually, no.
You know what, you're fine, you're a good man.
Uh-oh, this guy has a gun.
Wait a minute.
This guy has a gun.
We're part of the D-Gen Claw.
Oh!
You know what, you're chill, you're fine.
I'm on a scrap run, I'm poor.
You need scrap tea?
Let's fucking scrap out.
No, no, I have one right now.
Okay, okay, alright.
Bye!
Twinkle, we're supposed to be bad people.
Don't be friendly.
Yeah, we're supposed to be bad people.
We're part of D-Gen Claw, remember?
If we do all of this.
Just say we're part of D-Gen Claw.
I'mma shoot, I'mma shoot then.
And miss.
Should I, should I, should I?
He gonna turn around and murder us, Twinkles.
No, you're gonna end up hitting us.
Like, that's bad, that's bad, that's bad.
I've seen your aim.
That's, it's not good, it's not good.
Wow, wow!
Damn, where are we going anyway?
Where exactly are we going, guys?
We have a second base?
Okay.
No, please.
I don't, I don't want to have another lure dump.
I don't need another lure dump.
Stop, stop going to sleep, man.
I can't.
I get tired.
You're on the job.
I can't!
So, where is our second base?
I kind of feel like he's lying.
Like, 120?
A hundred and...
I kind of feel like he's lying.
He's just trying to convince us to run all the way home.
Oh, guys.
I would definitely...
We do have a second base.
No, we do have one.
Because they were like Helms or whatever.
N10.
N10?
Helms Deep Throat.
Oh, it's not even that far.
It's close by.
How come nobody else is heading there?
Why are they all still there?
Wait, should we just go to my...
I have a flashlight.
Let's keep moving.
Why is the rest of our group still back at the original house?
Are they...
I think they're gathering stuff over there.
Oh, I see.
Yeah.
No, let's keep moving.
Keep moving.
It's the scientist.
It's fine.
You're fine.
You're okay.
Save me.
He shot me in my ass.
You're okay.
Don't be a little baby.
Won't be a real DJ Klaus.
A DJ Klaus doesn't cry.
We're not DJ Klaus.
Yeah, but that's what we want them to think we are.
If they think we're DJ Klaus, they won't hurt us.
I'll do.
Oh, right, right.
Oh, okay.
You're thinking of...
You're thinking five head right now.
Yeah.
Yeah, like we bump into other people.
We got to tell them we're DJ Klaus.
So they don't hate...
And it'll be bad people.
So they'll hate us.
How does that work because of your clothing?
It's fine.
We'll just say we killed some Lurklings.
While we were running by and we were cold.
Oh, yeah, true.
Yeah, yeah.
I believe we have another base.
Like, what the fuck is going on?
Wait.
Theo, fucking turn off your fucking light.
Theo, put the light down.
I'm scared of the fucking dark.
Now, I'm gonna get hit by a wolf.
Theo, Theo, Theo.
Theo, I'm gonna make sure you see the dark all the time.
If you don't shut the fuck up.
What the fuck, Dakin?
You were supposed to be our boy.
Yeah, boy.
That's the only way to leave here.
You guys, we're done.
What the fuck?
I'm keeping the torch.
I'm so scared of.
We're looning, tooning.
I'm keeping the torch.
And Dakin, you are the biggest fucking scary cat in the world.
Is this guy scared of me?
We're gonna die.
Guys, guys.
Oh, my God.
What is this guy so scared of?
There's mines here?
You listen.
Yeah.
We're fine.
This guy is so freaking out about.
Yeah, there is.
We're in the mines.
Guys, I'm stuck.
Like, actually, never mind.
The mines are by the front.
I know that much.
Oh, okay.
So, there's no mines back here.
Oh, there it is.
Lorplings.
This is our new home.
This is our other home, right?
Where are the Glorplings?
The Glorplings.
What's up?
Wait, so we should put our sleeping bags here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then this, Tobi, here is the entrance.
Alright.
Hey, what happened to our sign?
What?
There's the Glorps.
Is that our mascot?
Is that not our- I'm not gonna lie.
This looks like a horror game.
What the fuck is this?
What the fuck is that?
Why is there a Dragon Ball over here too?
The first star Dragon Ball.
What the hell is going on?
What the fuck is this place?
I don't know.
Wait, wait.
We gotta have sleeping bags here.
Does anyone have extra sleeping bags?
There's some cloth right here.
I'll make you some.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Dude, this is too open.
How are we supposed to protect this place?
Well, they can just airdrop and then we die.
They can just jump on the rock and we die.
Woah, look at the picture of the Glorplings.
Wow, it really does look real.
That picture was taken earlier.
Alright, don't worry.
We'll be fine.
Oh my god.
Coconut is like an actual stalker.
You can block me onto my...
Woah, this guy needs to chill.
Alright guys.
DJ Claw.
I just don't know where I would safely put all this loot.
Because all this loot is worth way more than this base.
I think you should put it far away from this base.
I don't even think you should put it here.
Wait, wait, wait.
There's another base.
Follow me.
We have like another mini base nearby.
We can put it there.
Where exactly?
Oh, up the hill in the snow?
Yeah, where is the other base?
Why is...
Oh my god, there's a bear over there.
There's another bear.
There's always another bear.
Have they all successfully moved yet?
They've all been like gathered in that one area for a very long time and I'm a little worried.
We gotta go back.
Ah, they're celebrating because we won.
I'm a little...
I'm a little worried why they're still there.
I think it's a big party.
I think it's just a big party that we're missing.
Yeah, we should go back.
Wait, do you think they're having a wedding?
Oh, wait.
Maybe they are.
Let's go.
Maybe they're having another wedding.
Dude.
What the fuck is going on over there?
I feel like we should go back.
Where the fuck is going?
Wait, Gumi.
You missed out on a lot, Gumi.
We're in another war.
We're in another war again.
Are we going back?
I guess we are.
Yeah, I think so.
Fuck it.
Yeah, fuck it.
Let's go back.
I feel like...
I feel like it was...
I feel like they're having a party now.
Can't be that bad.
Yeah.
Whoa, that's a bear!
That's a bear!
I'm so excited!
No!
I get to...
What the fuck?
Now I'm here.
What?
What's going on?
Whoa!
What's going on, guys?
What's going on?
I feel so bad for Doki.
Here's what we're gonna do.
Okay, I'm gonna give you guys these orbs and I'm gonna walk Doki over to Helm's Deep Throat so she can see our new castle.
Oh no, I saw it.
I was there and then I got...
I was there but I got killed by a bear.
But don't worry, I'm fine.
Dude, Doki...
Doki arrived in the peak of like mid RP.
Had no idea what the fuck was happening.
It's like, what?
This also happened last time.
Let's see.
Lady Doki.
We...
Oh, this is the audio recording of everything that happened, by the way, Doki.
Oh!
Is that the war?
Is that what happened?
Yeah.
No, Jed, Jed wants a sacrifice.
Oh my god, Spongebunz, you're here too.
You've all submitted...
Okay, I'm assigning everyone tasks.
Yeah, Spongebunz and Doki.
Your guys' missions are to talk to other Lurklings so you can figure out what the fuck has happened recently.
Okay.
Lisa, you...
I guess go to Helm's Deep Throat and start securing it and just...
No, no, me, Dakken, Twinkles, and Theo secured it already.
We dropped stuff over there just then.
And then I got killed by a bear and now I'm here.
Now I'm here.
Wait, wait, wait, including the Forbidden Armory?
I'm gonna move the Forbidden Armory, don't worry.
I don't know what you're talking about.
What do you mean Forbidden Armory?
We have another Forbidden Armory.
You have another Forbidden Armory?
There's another one?
You mean the one where we had 5,000 scraps?
Wait, I said too much.
No, not that.
Not that.
No, no.
No, I didn't mean that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll talk about the Forbidden Armory.
Actually, Lisa, that'd be great.
If you can go to Helm's Deep Throat and make a special, like, reinforcement.
Like, you know that main keep area?
What do you mean by Forbidden Armory?
The biggest building there.
Make, like, an actual...
What do they mean?
The actual high-grade, like, nice...
I don't know what they mean by Forbidden Armory!
That's your task.
So, Dragon...
Okay.
Why are they still there?
Why?
Why are they not coming back?
I need milk animals up there fast.
There was more lore updates in the past 20 minutes?
What happened?
Who's Sven?
You guys are focused on this shit for tomorrow, right?
Yeah, so here's what we're doing, Sven.
We are abandoning the rock.
It's no longer safe to defend.
Sorry, I just had to do that.
We are going to Helm's Deep Throat.
It's our stone castle that's just north of the important area.
Okay.
Maybe we should build our castle, like, right next to yours, you know?
So we can put forces together.
Yeah, I would also have...
I would have you...
Yeah, maybe you and H shouldn't, like, scout out.
Like, well, actually, you're the main builder.
Yeah, you can figure out where the best...
Like, you know, we kind of built ours for aesthetics, because, you know, that's how...
You should probably build yours to be, like, sweaty, you know?
No, I'm not building sweaty.
I'm not building anything sweaty this week.
I will build something cool.
But, listen.
Listen, listen.
I was just called by a spy from Warkonnen.
Well, Warkonnen's leader just called me, okay?
They have a spy at their gate right now.
And apparently, they're going out...
DJ Klaw, sorry.
So, Warkonnen has a spy at DJ Klaw's gate.
Apparently, they're going out for another raid.
Another spy?
They might raid us.
They might raid...
I don't know.
They might raid the church.
How many spies are there?
I just want to let you guys know that if they do, we're going to go and raid their gen, okay?
You can't tell anyone.
If you tell anyone, we won't win.
So, if that happens...
If that happens, I'm going to write to you something in chat, Klaw.
And you'll know what to do.
Because there's no other way for me to reach you.
You guys don't have a phone.
You guys don't use that technology.
Actually, some of us do have phones.
I have a phone.
SirDragon has a phone.
You can...
Okay, okay.
Yes.
If that happens, just know, okay?
We will build a massive siege tower.
On F18.
On the north side.
Top left corner.
What the fuck is going on?
Just storm the walls with anything you have.
I'm sorry.
I forgot to mute my play.
Just place a bunch of bags around.
I'm sorry.
I'm so confused with the lore.
That caught me off guard.
We're going to fire rockets from our siege tower.
From outside of the wall.
And we won't push until everything is gone.
Because we have like...
We almost have like...
Was that the dragon roar?
I don't know.
If that's the case, if you guys can spare us anything at your raid bases.
The best part about Lurklings...
I don't know.
We have very strong skin.
We are tough.
So if you guys...
Not strong enough.
I got fucked over by a bear.
Or just like the most basic weapon.
We can just keep running in.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What I'll do...
What I'll do is...
I'm tied to a fucking bear!
I'll have supplies for you guys.
Like ladders.
And stuff.
And then I'll have them meet with you guys over there.
Okay?
But if you guys can put a bag there.
Just in case.
Or two bags or something.
One of you guys can bag everyone over there.
Are you ready?
I don't know if it's happening.
It's like...
I don't know what they're doing.
You know?
I don't know if you've seen their fortress, but...
Okay.
They got more turrets than...
They got like...
70 turrets or some shit.
They have 70 turrets?
What the fuck?
Yeah, no.
It's actually crazy.
How the fuck are we going to beat that?
Okay, so...
Yeah, I'll...
I'll call SirDragon.
The rats we are.
If it actually happens.
But I just want to give you guys a heads up.
So you know what we're doing.
Because it's going to be very hectic.
Oh, Dak is here.
Okay.
The other thing is...
If any of you guys have...
Extra...
Resources...
That you can spare.
We would love for you to fly them over to the rock.
Fly with...
Fly with my dragon.
Okay, goodbye.
Goodbye.
Hello, I'm back.
Do you still have...
Do you have my stuff?
It is time.
I have...
Wait, where are you?
Where the fuck...
What happened to Ella?
She's sleepy.
Wait, we won?
Like, actually?
I can make another armor.
Here's your minigun back, Ducky.
Oh, thanks.
And the bullets.
Did we kill the bear?
Did we do it?
Oh, thank god.
Wait, you didn't give me the ammo.
Theo,
you didn't give me the ammo.
Theo, you have the ammo.
No, he gave me rifle.
Nah, nah.
That's the ammo for it.
No, I got...
Wait, somebody else took it.
You gotta be at a...
You gotta be at a workbench to put the...
It's the 5.56 ammo.
Oh, I have to put it in a workbench.
Okay.
Oh, at least the bear is dead.
You have the ammo on you.
Oh, look at the bandages.
What the fuck?
Oh, they destroyed our workbench.
Oh.
This way, Ducky.
I'm taking a piss.
Alright.
Our base!
It lives!
Hey, it's still here!
Yeah.
If you jump on the bed, when you're on the bed...
Nice!
So, where's the workbench?
It's going to be on the second floor.
Alright.
I have to go from here.
Goddammit, I fucking...
You got it.
Okay, I got it.
It's going to be... This is right here.
And you just... When you open it in your inventory, you click on it and then you press refill.
Guys!
What does he mean by that?
Did it work?
What am I looking at?
Refill!
That's the research...
I was looking at the research, but I was very confused.
You don't look at it.
You gotta look in your inventory.
Alright, I got it.
I figured it out.
Nice.
Now we have...
Now we have our gun back.
Alright.
What the fuck?
I cracked the code.
I cracked it.
I don't like...
Getting out of this area is so scary, because it's all mines everywhere.
We gotta go back to Helm's Deep.
We gotta go back to Helm's Deep?
Alright, I'll see you guys there.
Wait, I'm gonna get my food.
I'm gonna fucking get some food.
Alright.
Grab some food and then...
And then we're gonna head off, guys.
The gun's health is practically non-existent?
How do you see that?
Guys!
I wanna fucking explore a little bit.
Where the fuck is... Why do we have green keycard?
Do we have any food at all?
Click on the gun?
What does it say?
Where do you see it?
Oh, you're supposed to see a green bar?
Yeah, I don't... I have no idea where that is.
Do we have any food left?
Where's the water?
I'll grab this.
We need backpacks and everybody needs to transfer stuff because I can't do that by myself.
Holy fuck!
How do we get all... Why do we not get looted?
Alright.
Does anyone have extra food?
Oh,
nice.
Thank you.
Oh, thank you.
I really needed that.
How about extra water, actually?
Alright, we leave.
Thank you for supplying us.
We leave now.
Now we leave.
It's time to dip.
Um, I'm... I'm done with... I'm done.
I'm fucking... I'm gonna go to the town.
Alright, let's just hope we can make it... Oh, there's my horse!
Aren't you that horse that I fuck... Oh, wait!
That's the horse I left!
Okay, we gotta be careful with all of my...
With all the mines around us, I'm a little bit...
Let's get our stuff back.
Hey guys, I stepped on a mine.
Let me get my stuff back.
Wait, why?
Why are you just leaving by yourself?
I saw a horse!
Oh my god.
Wait, don't take my stuff!
Wait, Lisa, that's my stuff!
Wait!
Lisa, don't!
That's my stuff!
I saw a horse!
Okay.
Alright, I'm okay now.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, everything... Okay, that horse is bait.
That horse is bait.
How is the horse alive?
How the fuck?
That horse was actual bait.
That horse was...
Of course I died to the landmine.
Of course.
Oh my god.
I hate... I hate living here.
I... I hate living here.
It sucks.
There's landmines everywhere.
Alright.
Alright, we're gonna head...
Who knew horses were blastproof?
Who fucking knew?
I... I need a map!
I need a map for... Oh wait.
Actually, I really wanna go gambling.
Let's go gambling.
I got a guitar.
I can just get a guitar?
Oh my god!
My luck has changed!
We found a guitar!
Everything is okay now in the world.
Everything is okay in the world now.
I'm feel... I'm happy.
I'm happy.
Things are finally looking up for Toki Bird.
Things are finally looking up.
I got a guitar and everything.
But nothing can go wrong now.
Yippee!
There's no way there's gonna be mines here.
There's no fucking way.
I'd be so sad.
I left the Lurkling's land just to get mine here.
I would be... No, you don't understand.
I would actually be so fucking sad.
I'd actually be so fucking sad if after everything I've been through, they still have mines here.
I'm like, I'm so far away from the Lurkling land that I still... Why did I join the one tribe with no guns?
Like, why did I do that to myself?
I could've had a gun.
I mean, I do have one, but I could've lived with the land of the guns.
You know what?
Who lives here?
Who's sleeping bag is this?
There's nobody's sleeping bag anymore.
No one's sleeping bag.
I'm from the D-Gen Claw.
That's right.
I'm part of D-Gen Claw.
That's what we do.
Stage to attack?
Everyone has to move there?
Alright.
I wanna go gambling.
I've been through so much.
At this point, at least let me have gambling.
Alright.
Oh my god, it's so far.
I wish I had my horse still.
I still have my horses.
Oh my god, it's so far.
I can't believe it.
If that horse wasn't bait, everything would be okay.
God, the town is so far from everything.
I need more scrap.
I need more scrap for gamble.
Oh my god, another guitar.
Maybe I can sell the guitar too.
More scrap.
More scrap for gamble.
Alright, we should be good.
That should be enough gambles.
Scrap.
Spikes.
Oh my god, two guitars?!
I swear, every time I come back, something...
I swear, I feel like I come back and it's like the season finale of season 6.
I'm like, what happened?
What happened?
Okay, where am I?
Okay, it's this way.
God, this is so difficult to navigate.
Oh, we don't want to go through the military tunnel.
No, we don't want to go through the military.
I only come... and then tomorrow, there's a big event too.
I mean, I guess tomorrow is the last day of rest.
I'll stream tomorrow as well.
I don't know how... does anyone know what time it ends?
Like rest tomorrow?
At least I can see my gun for like fucking one minute.
I literally saw my AK skin for one minute.
And then it's back to the lurking hours.
That's fine.
I'm gonna gamble a little.
Why didn't you just keep it?
I know.
Why was I trying to be nice?
Being nice never works for me.
Gamble the sorrow away.
You know like on Netflix, it's like...
Here's what you missed.
That's me.
Alright, anyway.
So, what the fuck?
Bruins, tissues, BoxBox, J-Mobile, Nike.
Oh, there's the Nike club!
The Zeus Caboose.
There's so many new shops now.
I think the meat shop is like...
I'm pretty sure the meat shop is like people.
I'm pretty sure.
It's always people.
That's the thing.
There's no way.
Does the biker gang still exist?
There's no way that the biker gang still exists.
I refuse to believe.
Oh, there's a rope.
What's this?
Does anybody live here?
Whoa.
Who lives here?
Why are there so many cards?
Oh, I could break that right now.
Who lives here?
Wait, I need to wear other clothes.
So they don't think I'm a lurkling.
I need to have like other clothes on.
Okay.
I need to be like...
Unlurkling.
Okay, wait.
There we go.
Now they won't know.
It's only one hit.
They won't know I'm a lurkling.
I'm just a regular guy.
I'm just...
Just trying to make it in this world, you know?
I'm just trying to figure out what...
I have no allegiance.
Just a dude, you know?
Just a dude.
Can't...
Can't get chased if I'm not part of the lurklings.
And they don't know.
Just a guy.
Just a regular guy.
Are they still gambling?
There is a war and they're gambling.
What the fuck are they doing?
They're gambling, aren't they?
Oh, they're fucking gambling.
Oh, I'm not gonna call him out because I'm joining them.
He is.
He's gambling too.
Oh yeah, we're making money for the lurklings.
Yeah, how much money did you guys make?
Oh, I don't really like that question.
You should be asking how much money are we gonna make.
Oh yeah, how much money are you guys gonna make?
A billion!
There's no fucking way I've lost 3,000 scrap in three turns.
There's just no way.
Wait, how much did you lose?
3,500 scrap in three turns.
I'm putting 150 on 20 and if this doesn't hit, then I have nothing.
Wouldn't it be funny if you lose everything, LM?
What would you do if you lost everything?
That would be funny because he took a loan out in my name and I need to pay it back.
Wait, who did you take a loan from?
Who?
Which?
Who did you take a loan from?
Who?
Bruce the loan shark?
There is a loan shark?
What does he do?
What does he do if you don't pay him back?
Who will he do to you?
Guys, I don't think it's gonna be red.
I don't...
LM, I'm one...
Listen, I'm one ketchup away, okay?
From making like 2,000 scrap and then we're back.
Are you like...
I keep betting 100.
Wait, wait, so...
So, like, basically, you need to win one red and then you'll be back to positive or back to zero?
Oh, okay.
You know, I'm...
So what does Bruce do when you don't pay back the loans?
Like, what does he do?
Oh, okay.
And where did you get this loan?
Like, where did you meet Bruce?
He's a little bit down the road from here.
Okay.
Yeah!
Yeah, I wanna see Bruce.
You know, I think all three of us should see Bruce right now.
I think...
I mean, LM, don't you need more scrap?
I'm gonna keep working it.
You go and then with... Okay, you go, Dougie, and then I'll keep... I'm gonna make money.
I don't wanna miss the red.
You keep winning.
Why is there so many pigs here?
Oh, my God.
I don't know, but because of the friendly zone, they won't attack you.
Oh, okay, okay.
I was like, what the fuck?
So, like, how much...
How much did you...
Borrow from this loan shark, LM?
And how much did Foolish borrow?
How much did...
That's not Bruce.
Loan subject to 50% interest day one and 50...
Well, no, I'm curious.
No, I'm curious.
I'm curious.
What happens if you don't pay back the loan?
Like...
Yeah, he lost everything, by the way, so I don't think he's paying it back.
Like, what happens to him?
You think he'll be...
So it says, like, 50% interest day one plus 50% each day after.
So...
So, like, how much scrap can I legally borrow?
Oh, and what do you mean by that?
Heads to collect?
Oh.
What do you mean by collateral?
Oh, I see.
I see.
Okay, so...
How much are you looking to borrow?
I mean...
I mean, if I leave, like...
I don't know.
I don't really have much on me right now.
All my other stuff is back home.
Yeah.
How much would that... How much would that get me?
Hey.
Yeah, you like that?
Ours doesn't look like that.
Yeah.
I got it off a dead body.
I got it off a DJN claw.
2,000?
Just 2,000?
Didn't LM get, like, 3...
That's all you got left?
LM got, like...
LM got, like, 3...
I think this is...
Okay, but this is, like, a real... This has, like, lots of kills on it.
I've killed, like, a lot of people with this.
Haha.
Wait, mine's about to...
Wait, this minigun's about to break, right?
Guys?
Oh, okay.
You know what?
Okay.
Alright.
You know what?
I'm...
I guess... I guess...
You know, I can make it back easily.
It's, like, holding it for, like, 10 seconds, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, that'd be fine.
Alright.
I thought it was a 2K.
I thought I could get 2K.
Hey, Foolish.
Wait, did you lose all your money, Foolish?
Wait,
I thought you said you only have 2K left.
He only has 2K left.
Yeah.
Foolish, how much... Do you need the scrap more than me, Foolish?
Uh, no.
I don't need scrap.
I'm about to make so much scrap back.
That's the thing.
Oh.
Oh, I see.
Is it possible to split it up 1K and 1K?
No, I rather... It's 2K or nothing for me.
Oh.
Oh, wow.
Yeah.
Does that sound great?
Alright.
Alright, good trade.
Good trade.
Yeah, great business.
Alright, Foolish.
How badly do you want this 1K?
Yeah.
Yeah, what's that gun you have there?
An M39 rifle.
Yeah, how much... How many bullets are in there?
Do you have an AK?
Uh, there's 7... There's... Uh, no.
I don't have an AK.
Oh, I guess we can't do any business with you then.
Oh, you want an AK or nothing.
Yeah, it's either AK or nothing.
Oh, yeah.
Hey, maybe they have an AK.
Time to go hit some crates.
Maybe they have AKs.
What, I'm gonna go to them and...
Yeah, ask if they have AKs.
Wait, I have an idea.
Can I make a loan on an AK?
Oh, you got a pretty big debt.
Wait, whoa, whoa.
You can literally ask Brutho.
I literally paid back my debt.
Yeah.
Are you gonna pay that one back?
Uh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Uh, let me see.
Whoa, what the heck?
Yeah, foolish.
Is that your name over there?
The 4,500?
How do some people have over 10,000?
Uh, they just let the interest accrue and forgot to pay.
Oh, you know what?
I have a better idea.
I am just gonna go hit the road and get some scrap.
Alright.
You wanna borrow an SMG?
Oh, no, no, it's fine.
It's all good.
You know what?
Don't worry about it.
I appreciate your business and I'm gonna make some money back.
Alright, we'll see you soon.
Alright.
Great service.
That's actually crazy.
There's loan sharks here now.
You're making it.
You're almost there.
Oh, this is a nightclub.
This restaurant has everything.
Does anyone have AKs?
I wanna trade.
I wanna trade for an AK.
Come try your luck?
Wait, what's the maze?
U17?
Where's that?
I wanna go to the maze.
Wait, maybe there's shops.
You're right.
A shop.
Tissue box, J-mobile, vending machines.
There's like vending machines, but like is there any actual?
Donations are accepted.
Frauds, stealing, exposed.
What the fuck is going on?
Boeing Co's casino?
We have a casino?
Oh my god, wait!
Press the drop bar.
50 scrap per...
Wait, is this the cas- Oh my god, wait, how do I drop the scrap?
Oh, okay, I'm gonna take this.
How do I?
Oh, did I just put 50 in here?
How do I separate this?
Oh, there we go.
No, that's not how I- Fuck, I don't know how to do this.
25.
Wait, where's my other scrap?
Why is it just 25?
Wait a minute, what happened to my others?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh!
Hey!
It's working!
748, 489.
50.
Wait!
Wait, I can make it back!
Oh, wait.
Hello?
Yeah?
Gumi?
Hey!
Did you know there's a gambling- There's a casino here?
I'm gambling.
Yeah, that's what I've been doing.
I keep getting 0.3.
Gumi, I took a loan from the loan shark.
Is that bad?
What do they do if I- What do they do if I- If I don't pay it back?
They didn't specify.
Oh, I lost it all!
What do they do?
Like, do I get to live?
Why did you do the dragon game?
The dragon game?
What's that?
Guys, I think this casino's rigged.
I think this casino's rigged.
Wait, I heard there's a maze.
I heard there's a maze.
It's like you something?
Guys, where's the maze?
I wanna do the maze, Gumi!
Steal a car.
Steal?
That's illegal.
Borrow a car.
Let's borrow a car from someone.
I don't know what they're roleplaying back there, but I hope it's fun.
I hope they have a good time.
We can steal this horse.
That was my horse, man.
Anyway, U7.
Where's U7?
Wait.
Wait, you...
Hey, Foolish, did you grab your scrap?
Oh, goodbye, Foolish.
U7?
U7's the maze.
You hear that?
Oh my god, there's an art gallery!
Ted!
I heard...
I heard you... I...
I got... Yes, I woke up from my coma, Ted.
I heard you're a fucking spy.
I heard from Tekken!
That you're actually a spy!
Woah, that was old of me.
That was old of me.
Yeah!
Look at me now.
Don't look more happy like that.
What is new you?
What is new you anyway?
Oh!
Oh, what the...
Woah!
Clearly, you're still the same you, Ted.
Oh!
Clearly, that's the same you.
You've never changed, Ted.
I knew you were trouble.
I knew you were trouble the moment I woke up from that coma four days ago.
I knew it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, let me go back to drawing.
Is that your art therapy now?
Look, look at this.
No, no, no, look.
What's this?
Isn't this insane?
This one?
What the fuck?
That's crazy.
Oh my god, this...
This one's insane.
Woah, my god.
What do you think about this one?
What do you think about these two?
Which one?
This?
This one and this one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
See, this is my first ever drawing and this is my second ever drawing.
Wait, so you became an artist after betraying everybody?
Wait, how did someone die?
So, you became an artist after millions of people died, Ted.
You just became an artist.
What do you...
Okay, just shut up.
What do you think about it?
It's very backwards of you.
Oh my god.
These are...
Oh my god, look at this cat.
Oh my god, woah.
Okay, that cat... that cat is really good.
That cat is a really good artist.
Da Vinci?
Oh my god, they're all cat drawings by...
Look at all these cat drawings.
Oh my god.
Wait, that's actually so pretty.
For like, on... on piece, like, for Rust.
Oh my god, it's Serial Ghibli.
Kiki's Delivery.
Have you tried drawing in Rust yet, Doki?
No, I've never tried drawing in Rust.
Stay wobbling.
You should draw, you should draw.
It's really hard, man.
Everything changes you.
I know, I know, I know it changed you, Ted.
It is.
Oh my god!
That's so pretty, Chad.
Oh my god, people are so talented here in the server.
Wait, people are insanely talented in this server.
That's actually crazy.
Is this drawn in Rust too?
Are they allotting?
Aren't all of them drawn in Rust?
Everything in this gallery?
Yes.
Everything in this gallery is drawn in Rust.
That's crazy.
Holy shit.
Oh my god, this looks amazing.
Doki, look at the eyeball.
Yes.
Which one?
Whoa!
Wait, that looks amazing.
Did you draw that, Monstera?
This one is by DaVinci.
And then we have more artists like Bee behind you.
These are my paintings up here.
Oh, it looks so good!
We have Kale, Wreck-It-Rabbit, and Joji.
That's an ad right there.
Oh my god, it's really cute.
It's really pretty.
Alright, Kumi, I'm ready to go to the maze.
Wait, what's wrong with the maze?
I'll see you in an hour, Doki.
See you in an hour.
It's super fun.
Doki, there's two horses!
There's two horses?
Alright, let's go.
Where's the other horse?
I fucking knew Ted was bad news.
I can't believe after everything he did, he went on and became an artist.
Alright.
Wait, do you have the coordinates for the maze?
It's like U something.
U7?
U18.
U18?
For the maze?
Hello, Kumi.
Kumi, take these.
Wait, why is your name red?
Who did you kill?
Just in case you get stuck in the maze.
You're 16, right?
If you get stuck in the maze, you can chop your way out.
You're 16?
Yeah, you're 16 on the river.
Alright.
Alright, Kumi, I follow you.
There's a fashion store?
Stop being ugly!
Oh my god.
What the fuck is this store?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Kumi, Kumi, Kumi, wait.
Wait, there's some stores here that's like I had to do a double take.
Hot zilfs.
Fashion and a boyfriend.
Not guaranteed a heart.
Stop being lonely.
What the fuck?
The fuck is a zilf?
Kumi, are you Kumi?
Kumi, no.
Kumi, it's a lie.
Kumi, no, it's a lie!
What?
Why was there an OOC?
What is that?
Wait.
What do you do with them?
Zombie, I...
Zombie, I love father.
Yeah, but like, what do you do with zombies?
Man, I love fishing.
Zombs, I love fishing.
Zoinks, I love fishing.
But what do you do with zombies?
What do you do with...
What the fuck is...
Oh my god, there's fighting!
There's fighting within the server!
Fucking Joey.
Wait, so like...
But like, what do you do with zombies?
Anyway...
I guess...
Alright, Kumi, I...
Kumi, I have...
I have 30 minutes left and then I have to go get dinner.
Because...
Because I need...
I haven't had...
I haven't had dinner yet.
Our last ride is into the maze.
You see it?
Where is it?
What is that?
Is that the maze?
Hello?
Is this the maze?
Yeah, do you want to try it?
Yeah!
I can let you in and start a timer.
Do you want to do it solo or do you want to go together?
Together!
Alright.
Make sure you have enough food, enough water.
You can drink in the river if you need.
Let me go check if there's any pumpkin plugs.
I ran out of pumpkin.
You know what to do!
Kumi, we touch...
We...
We touch right!
Hug right!
If you think it's gonna be that easy, I can let you in right now.
Wait...
Wait, okay, so like...
I'm gonna kill myself...
How long has this person been trapped in the maze?
I'm gonna shoot myself...
How long has that person been trapped in the maze?
There's some people that took 5 minutes, 8 minutes.
And there's some people that took over an hour.
You think that...
Is that lady the ones that have been in the maze for an hour?
Is she...
It's the second time in the maze and she's still in there.
She had to leave earlier for the wedding.
Because it took almost an hour.
Oh...
Okay...
Sometimes it takes longer, sometimes it's shorter.
Hi guys!
Alright, you know what?
You guys wanna try the maze?
Yeah, we wanna try the maze!
We got this!
Okay.
Okay, just so you guys are aware...
I know you guys are really good friends with us, like you know...
This is his time.
It's really funny.
Yeah, we can beat it.
That's so easy.
Just so you guys are aware...
Yeah?
Loads of people have been stuck for over an hour and can't escape.
So, are you two prepared mentally?
You should go separate, guys.
It's so funny talking to each other.
I can always save you, I just ran the maze again.
I know it now.
Nah, it's fine.
We should be okay.
Sure.
Take some food, take some food, take some food.
Where's more food?
Okay, okay.
Can...
I need more food then.
Thank you.
Alright.
We got this.
Let's go.
Okay.
Go, go, go, go, go.
I'm starting a timer, guys.
Can't be that bad.
Go this way.
We don't go that way.
Thank you.
You said hug right.
Hug right, hug right.
Guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys.
Hug right.
Who's telling you to hug right?
They might be wrong.
Wait, why are you trying to say...
I don't know why.
Are you trying to say that we're wrong?
No, I'm trying to say whoever's telling you...
Whoever came up with the idea to hug right in a maze like this is wrong.
How would you know?
Have you ever hugged right?
Yeah, I built this.
You built it?
Wait, why are you following?
Are you following us?
Why are you following us?
It's funny.
It's funny seeing how far people can or can't get right.
Doki, I want you to lead.
I don't have a lightbulb.
Guys, I don't...
I don't think we should hug right anymore.
I'm rubberbanding a little.
I don't know why.
What is...
That's part of the maze.
You have to crouch.
Is it?
Oh, I'm not...
Kumi.
Kumi, I think.
Kumi, I think I fucked up.
Kumi, where...
Kumi, where are...
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
This way is dead.
That's a dead end.
How would it take an hour?
It can't be...
That maze can't be that big.
There's no way here.
No, don't say that.
Don't say that.
Please, I want to go get food.
I want to eat.
I'll get something nice to eat today.
No!
Wait!
Second floor!
This is...
Okay, okay, okay.
Nice, nice.
Wait, how many floors is this?
How many floors is this?
Oh.
There's some extra information, guys.
There's some extra information that might help you out a lot more.
So...
Sometimes you have to go down in order to go up.
Down is up!
I always knew it.
I always knew down is up.
Wait, but then...
Who's telling you that?
It's my motto.
Down is always up.
Sometimes, though.
Only sometimes.
Oh, so that was just a bait.
Wait, but then there's this side, too.
Wait, there's another down here!
There's another down here!
Down is up!
And there's another up here!
Maybe we'll get another down is up.
Oh, yeah!
What do these markings mean?
So, the markings are what people left before you.
So, you see how you're dropping leather on the floor?
Yeah.
People have left markings.
Do you like us more than Saekuno?
Oh, hey.
That's a load of...
It depends on what time you get in the maze.
I'm saying, if you like us more than Saekuno, you'd let us be his time.
Oh.
Yeah, you guys can do that.
You might as well just stop the time right now.
Yeah, you might as well just, like, you know, let us, tell us where we're, you know.
Oh, yeah.
True, true, true.
Yeah, and just be like...
Are we on the third floor or the second floor?
Yeah, you guys are the best.
I can't even tell anymore.
This is the second floor, Doki.
Now, this is the first floor.
Now, we're at the first floor?
Well, over here...
So, this is one above the, like...
Are we on the first floor?
I think I called it...
This is the third floor.
I think we called them floors differently.
So, for me, it goes ground, then one.
Oh, yeah.
Alright, well, this server is based in America.
So, like...
Yeah, so...
So, it goes ground, then...
Doki, look.
We've been here before.
No, we haven't.
What's off the ground?
It's first floor.
Look at the freaking markings.
We talked about it.
No, no, but there's multiple markings.
You don't even know anymore.
There's multiple markings.
It's making me mad.
How long have you been stuck here?
I lost.
He's been stuck here for so long, he's changed his name to Lost.
He's literally lost.
How long have you been here?
He's a paid actor with a name Lost.
He's a paid actor just to be Lost.
What is this rubber band doing?
I'm going to get someone else to change their name to Minotaur later.
The Minotaur.
Look how slow I am.
I'm rubber banding so bad.
Are you crouching, Lost?
Have you got a keybind for crouch?
He's not even been 20 minutes.
Doki, this is good.
We haven't been here yet.
It's giving me...
I don't know.
I'm getting flashbacks.
This is new, Doki.
I don't think...
This is the top floor, guys.
This is the top floor?
This is the top floor, Doki.
Is this the top floor?
Down is up.
Down is always up.
This is a dead end.
Can we make it to the next floor?
I can't even...
All the floors are blurred together.
I haven't been trapped here.
How long have we been trapped here?
Did we go this way yet?
Did we go this way?
Oh, that's a dead end.
You've been in here for 6 minutes and 15 seconds.
I'm gonna kill myself.
I'm gonna fucking kill myself.
You have to say in-game.
You have to say in-game after that.
How long has this girl been trapped here?
How long has she been here?
The person trapped in here has been in there for like...
For like...
An hour now.
Are you okay, ma'am?
No.
No, I'm not okay.
I'm not okay.
There's a dead body here.
There's a...
Who is it?
What's his name?
That's...
It's...
It's your paid actor.
You didn't...
You didn't beat your paid actor.
What happened?
I bought him on Fiverr and his timer ran out.
His timer ran out.
Have you guys seen Johnny recently?
Why would he leave me?
I haven't seen Johnny recently.
Oh, I got such great acting.
But that's where we came from.
Maybe there's another down here.
There's another down to go up.
Yeah, but we must find another down.
There's another down here!
This is where we came from?
Is this where we came from?
Yeah, but is this where we came from?
Like, did we go up here?
Did we go up...
This is the second time.
You can't help him.
What do you mean?
Yes, he can.
I have something.
Yes, I can.
There's a reason why he can help us right now.
Because he's stuck here with us.
He's stuck here with us.
Oh my god.
I'd like a good story, please.
I was only allowed to talk to clay.
So I made clay figures, and I would talk to them, and I would evolve them like Pokemon.
And then, I think something in my brain snapped.
I don't know.
I really like this.
I love guys.
This clay guy is a cool guy.
I like Pokemon.
We went up.
Come here!
We did it!
Really impressive.
What's our time?
That was fast.
Oh my god.
What do you think it was?
How?
Was it faster than Saikuno?
Maybe 12?
No.
Oh my god.
There's no way.
It was faster than Saikuno.
No.
We did it!
This is not fair.
Yes.
That's not fair.
That's not fucking fair.
You just got in here.
That's not fair.
The Trauma Ducky W.
He's stuck in here with us.
Okay.
I think the maid didn't want your trauma anymore.
The Trauma Ducky W.
Guys.
I'm gonna write your names on the board.
Yeah!
We did it!
Gamer of the year right here.
Gamer of the year.
This should be my clip.
That should be my clip.
Oh my god.
She's crying.
How long have you been trapped there?
How many days has it been?
I don't know.
Okay.
Oh my god!
We have nine minutes!
Oh yeah!
Let's go!
Let's go.
We're so good at this.
We could have got faster time if we didn't threaten him.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna kill you.
Congratulations.
So.
Yeah.
Do you guys want to do it again and get an even better score?
No.
That's fine.
That's okay.
We're done.
Thanks for the maze.
It was a great maze.
Thank you so much.
GG's.
Tell Sakuno he sucks and I like you better than him.
Who says trauma dumping gets you nowhere?
I mean, I did threaten him with it.
I was like, you don't want it when she starts trauma dumping.
That girl is still trapped in there.
I can't believe the guy died.
I can't believe the paid actor died.
They're like, why didn't you say anything?
I can't believe it.
Alright, Gumi.
You want to take...
Is there a safe spot that you could take me where I can rest and not die?
Because I was sleeping.
Sleeping bag.
Alright.
I can't believe it, guys.
We're gamers.
I'm going back to the coma.
We're actually gamers, Gumi.
Look at us go.
Alright.
Woah, there's like apartments now?
I think we would've been rank one if we didn't threaten the tour guide.
We literally wasted time threatening him.
Yeah, we didn't spend time doing that.
Yeah.
Alright, I'm turning left.
Is this your new house?
Oh, that's our...
The friend.
Yep, I can't get out of the house.
Yeah, Hannah Montana, how do I get out of this house?
What's the code?
How would I know you'd be online?
No, no, 100%.
I got robbed last time.
In my own house.
Yeah.
Wait, where's my sleeping bag?
It's over here.
Is this mine?
I don't even remember.
No, my name was... mine was Hannah Montana.
How many doors?
Is this mine?
Where's my Hannah Montana?
It's this way.
Where's Hannah Montana?
Over here, over here.
Turn around.
How do I... how do I get off?
Oh, there it is.
And right here is your sleeping bag.
Oh my god, Hannah Montana!
Wait, I'm stuck.
I'm stuck.
Okay, nice.
Hannah Montana!
Alright.
Thanks for doing the maze with me.
Good luck.
Good luck with the rest of your day on the rest server.
I'll see you tomorrow on the last day.
I'll see you tomorrow.
Alright.
Wait, I'll message you in... are you going?
I'm gonna go get food.
I'm gonna go get dinner.
I know, you're getting food.
I know.
Alright, I'll see you later.
Are you gonna keep streaming?
I'll message you later tonight.
Alright, bye bye!
I'm going to go harass people for money.
Alright, bye!
Wait!
Here.
Did you log off already?
No, I'm here.
What?
Wait, I'm here.
I'm here.
What?
This is the safest spot.
Oh, this is the safest spot?
Yeah, because who's gonna fucking look in here for you?
I can't even... Okay, I can't get in.
I can't get in.
Maybe I'll just be here.
You gotta angle yourself, man.
You can't even get in!
What do you mean?
Okay, look who's in here!
Yeah, but you can't get in here!
Okay, I give up.
I can't do it!
You can't even do it!
You're in my way!
I'm literally 20 miles away!
I'm 20 miles away.
I'm 20 miles.
I'm not even...
Oh, yeah?
Oh, yeah, I'm in the way.
I'm in the way.
Oh, yeah.
You're making me nervous!
Turn around!
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, you... Turn around!
We just had three wars.
I'm tired.
How?
You turn around!
Okay, I'm turning around.
Yeah, you turn around!
You're not... You're watching.
How am I supposed to... I give up.
I'm fucking logging off right here.
Oh, my God.
I almost did it.
I almost had it.
How am I supposed to get out?
No, I'm not gonna do it.
How am I gonna get out?
Alright.
Alright, I'll see you later.
Bye-bye!
Bye!
Alright, everybody!
Oh, my gosh.
I streamed a lot longer than I thought I was gonna stream.
But I hope you guys...
I hope you guys managed to get some of your rest drops.
It was another eventful day.
It was another eventful day in Lands of Rest.
I'll be doing the final rest stream tomorrow.
And that would be the last day of the event.
So, I'll see you guys tomorrow.
What time will it be?
I'll tweet about it tomorrow.
I'll tweet about it tomorrow because I don't know what time it will be.
But yeah, we started a war and then we did a maze.
We started a war and then left.
Anyway.
Thank you all for coming.
For those who are new here, my name is Doki Bird.
I usually stream on YouTube, so please check me out there.
I usually tweet out whenever I am live on Twitch.
So, follow me on Twitter.
And you wanna know when I'll be streaming the rest drops again.
And you wanna support me via other means.
I do have merch being sold at the moment.
I have a concert next month, so check me out there.
Check out that concert too.
A 3D concert.
There's so many things to show for.
There's a lot of stuff.
I'm also nominated for VTuber of the Year, so feel free to vote for me there as well.
I did get nominated this week, so yeah, vote for me for VTuber of the Year.
There's a lot of things.
Do I even have a command for VTuber nomination?
I don't even know.
Guys, do I have... Do I even have a command for it?
I don't know.
Do I?
No?
Okay, I'll just link it.
I don't know.
So yeah, I got nominated for the Streamy Awards for VTuber of the Year, so...
Vote for... Is it the Streamy?
No, not the Streamy.
Sorry.
The... I'm sorry.
Wrong one!
Wrong award!
These streamer awards!
Sorry!
Sorry, there's so many!
There's so many stream awards.
Anyway, sorry.
The streamer awards.
And I got nominated in the VTuber category, so please vote for me there.
I have a PC case and keycaps, so you could purchase some of my stuff there.
There's so much stuff to show.
I think that's everything.
Anyway guys, as always everybody, stay hydrated, posture checked, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And you stay up for me?
Head to bed!
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!